is there some design principles that
were in your mind around saipai like is
there some key ideas that were just like
sticking to you that this is this is the
fundamental ideas yeah i would say so i
would think it's basically accessibility
to scientists like give them give
scientists and engineers tools they
don't have to think a lot about
programming so give them really good
building blocks give them functions that
they want to call and
sort of just the right length of
spelling
you know
there's a
one tradition in programming where it's
like you know make very very long names
right and you can see it in some
programming languages where the names
get you know take off the screen and
i in
in the 4chan world characters would had
to be six six letters early on right and
that's way too too much too too little
but i was like
i like to have names that were
informative but short so even though
python
well this is a different conversation
but uh documentation is doing some work
there so when you look at great
scientific
libraries and functions there's
there's a richness of documentation that
helps you get into the details
the first glance that a function gives
you the intuition of all it needs to do
by looking at the headers and so on but
to get the depths of all the
complexities involved all the options
involved documentation does something
that is essential yeah so that was
actually a
so we thought about several things one
is we wanted plotting we wanted
interactive environment we wanted good
documentation these are things we knew
we wanted the reality is those took
about
10 years to evolve
right given the fact that we didn't have
a big budget it was all volunteer labor
it was sort of
um
when nthot got created and they started
to you know try to find
projects people would pay for pieces and
they were able to fund some of it
not nearly enough to keep up with what
was necessary and i'm no no criticism
just simply the reality i mean it's it's
hard to start a business and then do
consulting and also promote an open
source project that's still fairly new
cyborg is fairly niche
we stayed connected all while i was a
student sorry a professor i went to byu
and started to teach electrical
engineering all the applied math courses
i love teaching uh signal processing
probability theory electromagnetism i
was the if you look at rate my professor
which my kids love to do
i i wasn't like i got some bad reviews
because
people
was a criticism um i would speak too
high too high of a level like i
definitely had a calibration problem
coming out of uh graduate work
where i hate to be condescending to
people like i really have a ton of
respect for people fundamentally like my
fundamental thing is i respect people
sometimes that can lead to a i was i was
thinking they were
they had more knowledge than they did
and so i would just speak at a very high
level yeah assume they got it but they
need to rise to the standard that you
set i mean that's one of the some of the
greatest teachers do that yeah and i
agree and that was kind of what was
inspiring me but but you know you also
have to
i i cannot say i was uh i was articulate
to some of the greatest teachers right i
was you know like one classic example
when i first taught at byu my very first
class it was overheads transparencies
overheads
before projectors are really that common
so transparencies i'm writing my notes
out i go in room's half dark i just
blaring through these transparencies
here it is here it is here it is
and i gave a quiz after two weeks
never knew anything
nothing i had gotten anywhere
and i realized okay i'm not this is not
working so i took put away the
transparencies and i turned around to
start using the chalkboard
and what it did is it slowed me down
right the chalkboard just slowed me down
and gave people time to process and to
think and then that made me focus my
writing wasn't great on their chalkboard
but
i really loved that part of like the
teaching so that that entered scipy's
world in terms of we always understood
that there's a didactic aspect of sci-fi
kind of how do you take the knowledge
and then produce it
you